[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're unaware this is a segment
where viewers try to find mistakes on
our show we're the only show that really
encourages people right try and find us
making a mistake I would say we're the
only show that can yes because we don't
make mistake the other shows are like
Swiss cheese
exactly I guess and we're Brie I don't
know hundreds of challengers so far over
the times that we've been here at TBS
not one mistake not on Scott a swimmer
tonight tonight a fan named Bradley
Miller says he thinks he got us he says
I made a mistake he says it happened
during a recent comedy sketch High Conan
recently I saw you're doing a comedy bit
about overly specific Hillary Clinton
logos needed a logo about Jared Leto who
you pronounced Jared Leto there's one
for straight men who occasionally find
themselves attracted to Jared Leto so
when I first heard that I just thought
oh maybe he just hasn't met Jared Leto
before but then I did some more
investigating I actually saw that you've
interviewed him on the show and he have
a picture of it on Team Coco calm Conan
you have two options either try to prove
me wrong or to apologize to Jared Leto
immediately
[Applause]
guy thinks he's got me yeah a guy also
has a lot of free time yeah
all right listen Alison I would
apologize young man I would I would
apologize if I were wrong but I never am
and I'm not now you see Jared does not
pronounce his name Leto he pronounces it
Leto and I have proof
you yourself referred to Jared's
appearance on our show well if you would
actually watched that appearance you
would have seen this my first guess is a
talented actor a musician who's appeared
in numerous films including Fight Club
American Psycho and Dallas buyers club
please welcome Jared Leto
[Applause]
jared leto
please welcome Jared Leto
[Applause]
jared leto
[Applause]
[Music]
what's going on with those people are
there
[Applause]
they're fans of you but they're wearing
my hair Leto
[Applause]
right yeah and he said Leto's seventy
five more times riding that interview
yeah he just kept saying lead oh yeah
you know it's like a burp for him yeah
anyway the challenge still stands if you
think you sported an arrow on our show
reported a team koco.com slash haha i
found an error we all sorted out right
here on the air let's see if you have
what it takes to make chuck meat out of
me the maestro wasn't that a great clip
subscribe to my youtube channel for an
endless supply of me
[Laughter]